Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and some serious
Berserker shit went down in the finale.
I also wanted to give a quick shout out to
Arden Cho who plays Kira on the show.
Thanks for retweeting me while the episode
was melting everyone’s faces.
They did a good job of blowing everything
up in our faces and teasing some nice things
for season 5.
There’s a whole lot to process so this video
will just be for the finale then I’ll post
season 5 predictions tomorrow morning.
Be sure to subscribe to get that if you’re
just finding me for the first time.
If you guys are wondering what to watch now
that Teen Wolf is gone for a while I’ll
make a few recommendations at the end of the
video.
But careful for spoilers if you haven’t
seen the episode yet.
I’m going to do my Top 10 WTF moments and
then my review.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, everybody ready.
Let’s go.
Number 10 - Berserker Scott Tries to Kill
Kira
I like how they focused the camera on his
eyes when Kate was explaining he hadn’t
ever killed anyone before.
Even if he killed someone now though, his
eyes would still glow Alpha Red.
It’s only when they’re not an alpha that
the colors can be different.
Unless you’re some other kind of creature.
Who else is bummed Lydia’s eyes don’t
glow?
I really wanted a deeper dive into the mechanics
of berserkers but they’ll probably add that
to the DVD commentary if they do one.
Or someone can ask them at the next convention.
9 - Derek Gives Liam the Talisman
What three things cannot stay hidden.
I loved the Team Sterek moment they shared
while Derek was trying to help Liam.
I was fun to see him flip during the full
moon but I really wanted to see him hulk out
in the big final battle.
I guess that’s something they’re saving
for Season 5.
He took a bit of a backseat for the rest of
the finale, but had they gotten a 4b this
year.
I feel like that’s when he really would
have started to stand out.
8 - Lydia with a Baseball Bat
I really hope she joins the softball team
next year.
That’s not going to happen but there was
this really funny thing going on when I had
a flashback to the episode where Lydia and
Stiles are at the Lacrosse field and he has
a baseball bat and she says, we need to find
someone better with a bat.
Cut to now, she is the better person.
I think that tells you a lot about where she’s
headed in season 5.
7 - Peter Asks Malia To Kill
Peter just wins dad of the year awards all
around.
First he asks her to kill, then he knocks
her out cold across the room.
I’m sure she’s not going to have any lingering
daddy issues whatsoever, not at all.
I feel like with the half a season thing going
on, they didn’t get enough time to fully
explore Malia.
They hinted from episode to episode that she
was slowly getting used to being a human.
But then you have the “deer” moments when
you still see the coyote brain poking through.
That would be a good nickname for the other
pack members to call her when she spaces out.
Coyote Brain.
It’s super illegal to just straight up post
clips of the show to youtube, but I would
really like to see just a compliation of Malia
reacting to things.
It would be called “Malia Doesn’t Understand”.
Her clinging to stiles makes a lot more sense
now given what Peter has put her through.
She’s just going to double down on family
time with the pack.
6 - We Still Don’t Know What Parrish Is
I was almost a little upset they didn’t
spend the money to do a full on CG transformation.
They really are saving a lot for Season 5.
He’s still one of those in between characters
who acts like a normal person, but knows the
whole story about the pack.
I think Stiles Dad is still going to be the
anchor to the real world and Parrish will
start floating into the world of the pack.
And the bestiary book at the end was a nice
tease.
5 - Chris Argent Let’s Kate Go
Remember how I said none of the beautiful
people were going to die.
There were really two big takeaways I had
from their scene.
First, Kate is a little nutters but she’s
like the Peter of the Argent Family, she still
wants to restore their power.
And Chris is the Derek.
He’ll never be able to kill his sibling
no matter how terrible he or she gets.
Plus there’s the whole Desert Wolf thing
going on.
Does anyone else feel like it might be Kate?
Before I thought kate I assumed it would be
a new character we hadn’t seen yet.
I’m kind of still hoping that.
I feel like Peter and Kate would have been
too high on themselves to hook up and have
a baby.
4 - Kira Learns To Heal Herself
Couple of awesome Kira Moments here, the healing
factor was another thing they didn’t get
too mechanical with.
Jeff Davis said during Wolf Watch that when
they were writing Kira this season they had
to pick which bits of the Kitsune myth they’d
give to Kira.
Like they have all kinds of powers but they
didn’t want Kira to be able to do anything.
They picked healing because it tied the process
back to Scott and the Pack.
She’s taking on more wolf like qualities,
even if she’ll never be a wolf.
Groups of people that are really close will
eventually start to absorb each other’s
personality traits, so of course Kira would
start healing herself like the wolves.
Did anyone else feel like her mom was giving
her tough love too.
In a funny kind of way.
Like she was saying, figure it out on your
own.
Just walk it off.
Just a flesh wound.
Kira’s mom is also hundreds of years old
which the show hasn’t mentioned since 3B
so I feel like it’s authentic for her to
be so detached.
She’s literally seen everything a person
can do.
Nothing surprises her, unless it’s demon
stiles breaking her last fox tail.
3 - Kira Gets Her First Foxtail
This was the other side of that.
Everybody in the episode wins an award for
making it through another challenge.
Kira’s reward is her first fox tail.
As she gets more powerful season to season,
she’ll accumulate them until she gets all
9.
As far as I know in the mythology, 9 is the
most they can have.
I’d really like to see some bonus content
either webisodes or something else where Kira’s
mother tells her the stories of how she got
all 9 of her fox tails.
They’re all gone right now, but if Kira
had to almost die and evolve to get the first
one.
Imagine what she’s going to have to do to
get the other 8…
That also reminds you what a badass her mother
is.
2 - Peter Was the Benefactor
Not really a surprise, I think after the last
episode it was all but confirmed he was trying
to get his alpha power back via scott.
And as expected, he totally went down hard.
They said they specifically made Ian Bohen’s
wolf makeup to look like Ducaelion’s just
to call back to season 3A and Scott’s struggle
to become the true alpha.
I love that they let Peter be the grand shakespeare
villain again.
It was fun to see him play normal in the first
few episodes too.
I feel like he and Derek have that Loki Thor
relationship that will be interesting to see
in season 5.
I’m pretty sure we’ll see a whole lot
of people coming to visit Peter.
Especially Malia, trying to learn more about
the Desert Wolf.
Because of her, Peter still has something
that the pack needs, or that Malia needs and
by default the pack.
So he’s not going away anytime soon.
The Valack Peter Ship will be strong next
year too.
Big Question: In their little prison situation.
Is Peter the wife?
I think is, which is a nice way to laugh about
him given all the terrible shit he pulled
this year.
And my Number 1 WTF Moment - Scott Evolves
Into The Black Wolf
Jeff Davis explained that they knew this is
where derek would end up before they ever
started writing season 4.
Because Derek’s journey isn’t about being
the alpha they had to evolve his character
in a different way.
For all intents and purposes, he’s just
become the perfect form of what a werewolf
can become.
Being able to shift completely into wolf form
is the something only a true master can pull
off.
So he’s just like super Zen Obi Wan Kenobi
wolf now.
I predicted that he’d get his powers back,
but I was totally surprised by the way they
explained it.
And as cool as Derek joining the sheriff’s
department would have been, clearly they have
something else planned for him next year.
But now it’s your turn.
Let me know, were you happy with what they
did to Derek and do you think the Desert Wolf
is Kate or a new character?
Here’s a few general thoughts on the season:
Favorite Moments from the season - Derek Evolving,
Scott showing his true alpha form, Kira on
the lacrosse team, Liam joining the pack and
Malia and Stiles, Malia was probably my favorite
new pack member, but technically she wasn’t
new.
My Most anticipated new pack member is Parrish.
I can’t wait to see him learn about who
he is.
My current best theory is phoenix.
I’m a little disappointed there’s no 4B,
but really the story will still pick up the
same place it would have had things been different.
So I don’t think we’re missing any potential
stories.
There are a lot of rumors Season 5 might be
their last, but I think it’s too soon to
tell.
Overall the finale was a nice conclusion to
the benefactor arc, I gave it a solid B plus
for evolving all of the characters.
Derek was the only one to say it out loud.
But all of the characters evolved over the
course of the season.
Malia is evolving into a human, Scott into
a true alpha, Lydia into a fully actualized
banshee.
Parrish into a phoenix.
I’ll just keep saying phoenix until I think
of something better.
If there’s anything I thought could have
been better it was just explaining a lot of
the magical aspects.
If any of you guys watch Legend of Korra,
that’s a show that explains it’s special
abilities in great detail.
Part of the reason I make videos is to learn
more, so please more explainers about the
mechanics of the bestiary.
If any of you are supernatural fans, that’s
another show that takes it’s literature
really seriously a la Men of Letters.
But overall, great end to a much more human
oriented season.
I really liked this season more than 3B just
because the let the pack act more like teenagers
and less like demon hunters.
It’s a lot easier for me to relate my own
experience to them when they face family problems,
girlfriend problems, high school problems.
Like Math.
Like I said, I’ll be posting my season 5
predictions tomorrow.
Be sure to subscribe to get that.
Since Teen Wolf is gone for a while, here’s
a few shows I want you guys to check out.
Hint, Hint I’ll be doing videos for all
of them.
The new Monday Night Shows are Gotham on FOX,
that starts at the end of the month.
And Star Wars Rebels, that doesn’t start
till october.
But I’ll be doing bonus videos starting
next week.
Then The Flash with Grant Gustin is coming
on Tuesdays in about 4 weeks on the CW.
Then Supernatural and Agents of SHIELD season
2.
All awesome shows.
SHIELD is on ABC.
Arrow is my Wednesday show, if you’re not
watching it you should start right now.
They’re basically doing justice league on
tv.
It’s bad ass.
And Friday Constantine, the other DC Comics
TV Show is coming in October too.
I’m working on a fall schedule for all the
videos I’ll be doing, so look out for that
this week.
But feel free to suggest anything you think
I should check out.
Right now click here for last week’s Teen
Wolf and click here to start getting ready
for Arrow Season 3.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!